oh what'd you think of my cutout Shelly
it's good I'm gonna get me some more you
want some yeah maybe I'll oh no actually
little--it I think I'm good
you're perfect just have to fart let it
help
it's from the chili ah no it feels like
a little man with cleats inside of me
just dancing all over my uterus not from
that Shelly let me call you an ambulance
or something
wait do you know how much like cause I'm
unless you're paying for it I'm not
paying for it you better use Google is
pretty alright symptoms
do you have mood swings what mood swings
yes oh that's not good do you have
abdominal bloating no it's a little
pudgy okay I got a cool search
you're a mother
so plus weight have you been having sex
no I haven't asked like son forever it's
like Hollywood's up there so how did you
get pregnant I know how Monday night
salsa night I danced with this guy named
Julio and I didn't have sex with them
but those dance moves can make anybody
pregnant mMmmm so what are you going to
name the baby we should name her son
Elias no I feel like I'm gonna name him
one the second one the second one
oh why Mon one yeah because it's the
accent that they have hmm that they do
oh I like that in a second because it
makes it like royalty oh is it the act
in the royalty okay so wait before you
go posting on Facebook you know I just
want to make sure that you're really
pregnant okay some of the symptoms say
light bleeding and spotting yeah I'm on
my period no dumbass you can't be
pregnant and on your period so there's
no one there's no more hot one be sick
no one there's not one and there's not
one you're not you're not typing fast
enough i'ma favor this out do you have
shortness of breath now that you say
that I think I do do you have headaches
yeah like a lot of times when you talk I
get them really bad migraines huh mm-hmm
do you have blurry vision I feel like
sometimes I can't see par yeah cuz you
don't like my Instagram post so your
vision must be [ __ ] up yeah I didn't
see it
oh my god is that like a cold I can't
tell you this you have to read it for
yourself what your dying business pretty
busy they say the good die young I'm
gonna be so famous ever since you're my
best friend
my world of Earth me
I'm going to give you my heart ik my
selfie stick a selfie stick yes you
earned it
you're such a good friend lately I just
Lulu I'm not even dead yet
huh I was just taking pictures of us you
are dying I'm gonna tag you in all my
pictures you're gonna live on through my
pictures god you're smart yes okay well
I want them to remember me in a good way
so just get it written word angle yeah
make people want to like that you're
dead and like have a reason to like the
picture sit sweaty little sweat it out
your back more I'm gonna break my back
little them and dying what do you do
acrobatics I'm dying
Lulu it's not gonna hurt you're dying
it's gonna be okay got it yeah okay
take care of it I will wait Lulu it says
here I would have one ear you have two
ears yes my hair just covers up the
loved one oh that's not cool so I'm not
dying you're not dying
can I keep yourself a stay no Breanna my
stomach is still killing me though we
have to figure out what it is
alright symptoms and I get nightmares
sometimes I'm possessed I get it
I would do the same thank you for coming
father
release huh don't say Ted get behind V
not you Lulu
over there don't spare but the power of
Christ compels you let the power of
Christ compels you
I'm so sorry that is my vodka sorry that
hold that Lulu thank you so much yes
Father
huh let the power of Christ compels you
look the demon is release yeah cool
ready go it was delicious
it's my chili haircut there Killian you
would have to give me the recipe oh my
stomach
oh we should google it it's free I'm
going to give you my car my selfie
Steger cards did we nail that you are
it's probably terminal Richard I don't
think you have long I think it's gone it
like a sight soon you're gonna just do
it just do it yeah ah all right
is your vision blurry I feel like
sometimes I can't see part yeah or cuz
you didn't like my Instagram post so
yeah I didn't see it you didn't see it
we can't do much come on like this oh
hey audio jump